so let's talk about uh your tag because
you have one of the more iconic tags in
hip-hop
uh and i always say you know i had a
conversation with hit boy and hippo was
saying for the longest time he didn't
have a tag and it kind of hurt him
because you know we think of like hit
boy as like one of the more legendary
producers of all time but some of his
biggest fans
don't have his name on him as a you know
so he started using a tag
your tag is very iconic at this point um
how did you find your tag what like like
kind of break down the story of how you
got your tag so the the murder on the
beatso is not nice tag um me and baca
shout out to baka yeah shout out to baka
we were um we were like recording in
toronto and then like he just said that
on the track and i was like i should
kind of use that then one day sunny
digital was in toronto and i was like yo
like should i use this to the tag and i
play the song he's like you should you
should try it out
and then i started using it and then
drake told me to put it on everything
from there on and then that's how it
came about and now it's like but like
my old mama murder tag i got that [ __ ]
like i like bought it off some guy on
the internet for like 20 bucks he like
made it for me and i wanted that because
i was on mixtapes and [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying so
when you're listening to a mixtape no
label 2 some some old kind of mixtape
you listen you hear my tag you'd see
produced by murder and that's what was
driving like beat sales people would hit
me up on twitter whatever like yo it's
like an advertising what i'm saying that
was how i was getting money so i was
trying to like promote myself and build
my brand you know no you've done a good
job at that um
when you first started it kind of like i
always feel like with producers now
there's so many different avenues for
you to be
like support yourself as a producer
because we always think like the
placement game is like such a
a tough game if you're a up and coming
producer
like chasing placements going in the
studio trying to get your beats in the
right people it's hard especially now
too man because now it's like when i was
coming up there was probably like
500 producers thousand producers trying
to do it on the internet now there's
like 10 million it's wild 50 million
literally like 50 million kids so it's
like if you're trying to chase a
placement on an album and you get that
album cut on a big artist like how are
you supposed to even build a brand off
that right you know like i feel like the
biggest way for a producer to
build nowadays is
to build come up with an artist and
build a sound you know what i mean yeah
like find an artist that you [ __ ] with
do the whole album
then they blow up and then you know what
i'm saying that i feel like that's like
the best way to build a brand yeah
because you build a sound you know what
i mean i think the uh what's the one
kid's name uh
logic's producer him like logic's
producer did like all of his [ __ ] and
like obviously that dude's got a grammy
and all that [ __ ] but yeah and then you
and then you're like associated with an
act and like that [ __ ] goes a long way
you know what i'm saying yeah i mean you
kind of like in a way kind of did that
with the amigos early on yeah you know
you were kind of synonymous with like
what they were doing because the thing
is with them is like back then like they
were only [ __ ] with like three four
producers and i was one of them or like
three to five they had like a few you
know what i mean but like they were not
[ __ ] with anyone else's beats and
like no one can get a hold of them so
like you know what i mean just being a
part of that was like very exclusive and
like everybody wanted my beats